he plays Newt Scamander and fantastic
beasts and it's mr. Eddie Redmayne hello
hey Conan my god and you hear a lot
about 4-h it's it's bigger than you
think it's going to be this is
extraordinary for us to be here we're so
excited and for what I want to do we're
going to need a bit more light if it's
all right with you
I'm just going to Loomis
I need more light than that
I'm sorry any I know lighting very well
and I know this hall that's as bright as
Indy go absolute limit of brightness
I'll be catastrophic
um but perhaps I could do is get some
but I did it I'll get some help
sure just come down no idea where he's
going
she's unprecedented I don't know where
any red meat is going I don't know what
he's doing I think I couldn't even it
worked I can see someone's but I've got
a few special ones here so if I could
just start can I give you that one for a
stuff ok I think this is going to take a
water I might need some more ok alright
take that one and that one over here ok
I understand what's happening now Eddie
Redmayne has gone into the crowd and is
handing out wants chew everybody in the
hall
was coming that's what happening told
right now he's going to get some help
several hundred people from Warner
Brothers are now entering the audience
everyone here is going to get their own
one
any SSI I told that he do not go into
the crowd it's a rabid crowd they're
insane fans he went against my wishes he
is now going through the crowd and every
single person here is going to get their
own one on your one because once you
have it we're going to need you to use
it any now working his way through the
crowd he's really going all the way back
into all age college is over 15 miles
deep if CJ's have you've got a 1 when
you hold it up if you've got a 1 hold it
up if you don't have a wand don't hold
anything else because that would be
confusing
once you get your wand prepare for your
orders and she's just working a club and
he's still working his way to the back
ball age where he is personally handing
out ones to everybody here with the help
of over 10,000 people from Warner
Brothers each one paid very little I'm
just throwing that in myself now I'm
bantering while Eddy and Warner Brothers
people are handing out guns lucky the
ones if you need a wand you will get a
one everyone is
one when this process is done here comes
Eddie he's working his way now down from
the front of the hall I love it
he's meeting all kinds of people in the
audience now I know it's confusing Eddie
Redmayne and I look a lot alike
many of you when you see Eddie will
think you're meeting Conan because we
both have that very light Celtic skin
well that was actually going to see
anyone here is going to get a wand make
sure you get a one ladies and gentlemen
people are handing them out from Warner
Brothers Eddie is back let's hear it for
Eddie Redmayne Jamaican all the way to
the back of college that was incredible
you raise your ones in the air guys just
so I can see how it doing you have a one
raise it in the air all watch being
handed a spectacular sight for me so I
was wondering if you could help me if on
the count of three we could do a limb
with maximum so raise your ones in the
air one two three Lumos maxima
one incredible special event
music so I kind of want to record how
embarrassing that will you hold your
words in the air because while you're
watching here a new snapchat Channel a
Wizarding World snapchat Channel and I
am the least technologically competent
person in the whole world
have a phone and I'm going to try but
I'm screwed up and take this picture so
we can all raise your hands well this is
going to be like the first launching
moment fantastic bees I've got shaking
hands so this could be all blurry Amanda
focus honey amazing now I need to know
what to do with it so I'm just going to
fiddle here and do something I look like
a psychopath in the photographic you
look new
this is going incredibly well I think
what ideas she says aren't actually
conviction touch stupid anyway thank you
for joining
shot of you can everyone wonder want to
the air and I will get a shot of all of
you and your ones in the air with the
idea in the foreground one last quick
shot this will go out very nice let's
hear it thank you much an incredibly
talented actor mister getting Redmayne
you